peut pas avoir une grande race à son
image en magasin benjamin castaldi vous
n'avez rien tourné
donc vous vous dites qu'elle et mara
sera ce soir 10 numéros de téléphone non
non ça suffit
alors alors alors benjamin j'avais
raison je ne vais pas donner votre
numéro
mais mais ça va être pire et affament
benjamin vous déménagez aujourd'hui on a
des images mais non
et un deux trois quatre
à tabac benjamin valeur ajoutée sorti
major c'est bien suivi en direct
non la cité cet après midi vous
déménagez aujourd'hui bajaur oui il fait
savoir dans quels coins de la capitale
vous déménagez approximativement
approximativement à la fin sa loi je
suis en relation jeunes ont lieu soit
pas bien
paris semble beaulieu rioux bonn ouest
banlieue et bien benjamin savais que je
vous aime énormément fait il avait
choisi pour votre déménagement
benjamin je payais non mais je vous aime
énormément je vous le dis et benjamins
ce soir j'ai décidé de réaliser votre
rêve en eau la lah en direct pour la
grande race track à tu sais ça c'est mon
frère salem énormément tube qui l'a aidé
merci à toi je te fasse un gros bisou
non je veux rien de toi là y'a rien ça
va être la norme n'est pas dans ma
nouvelle maison
c'est pire non je suis pire que dans
votre nouvelle maison
benjamin vous m'avez dit que vous aviez
toujours rêvé d'habiter au bord de l'eau
donc je me suis occupé du déménagement
benjamin je me suis occupé du
déménagement et benjamins j'ai décidé de
vous faire habiter vous et votre
dulcinée aurore votre femme qu'on aime
énormément et vos cartons bien sûr au
bord de l'eau j'ai un duplex on dit en
direct avec votre nouvelle maison
benjamin ce benjamin regarde jamais
c'est mes affaires j'ai bien roulé a
vraiment fait mal mais en plus vous êtes
au bord de l'eau douce est mis au bord
de la seine lundi dans le salon est-ce
qu'on peut aller dans la chambre s'il
vous plaît je connais dans le maire au
regard des ja qui dans la ligne à qui
ouais y'a qui dans le nid de cheveux
mais vous êtes au bord de la seine
mais si nous avons voisins mais qu'il
arrivait alors vous êtes au bord de
l'eau où vous êtes au bord de la scène
je vous avais besoin de la scène qu'on
soit synchro bah oui je vais rentrer
maintenant la salle des acacias
bah vous là les rejoindre afin de tuer
aussi bien la nouvelle chambre devait la
rejoindre un film drôle de tête
j'adorais chambre a stoppé ma table
buzet lumière combien j'apprécie cyril
si on savait qu'on allait les quartiers
très bien là bas tu as un truc à dire à
ta femme tu peux rien pour attendre
les rames en est ce qu'on peut appeler
les séries c'est vrai est-ce qu'on peut
allumer les chéris nord allumé allumé à
lui mais bien s'énonce appris mais
l'ajustement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m